the domain name system or dns is like
the phone book of the internet it maps
human readable urls or host names like
www.fireship.io
to the ip address of the server that
hosts that site when you type a url into
the browser
it makes a dns query to figure out which
unique ip address
is associated with that hostname first
it'll attempt to look in the local
browser or operating system cache
but if the cache is empty then we need
to look up the ip address in the phone
book which is the job of a server
known as the dns recursive resolver it's
recursive
because it needs to make multiple
requests to other servers starting with
the root name server which itself will
respond with the address of a top level
domain dns server which stores data
about top level domains like
com or dot io the resolver makes a
request there which will respond with
the ip address of the authoritative name
server
that's the final source of truth that
contains the requested website's ip
address that gets sent back down to the
client
and is cached for future use that sounds
complicated but it all happens within a
fraction of a second
you can think of it as a globally
distributed database that handles more
requests than any other database in the
world
when you register a domain name it's
handled by a registrar
accredited by the non-profit
organization icann the record is then
maintained by a registry operator who
stores your dns settings and propagates
them to
other dns servers around the world as
the registrant you'll be assigned a zone
file where you can configure
the settings of your domain every zone
has a startup authority record
to tell other dns servers who's in
charge of that domain
but most importantly we have the a
record it means address
and maps a domain or subdomain to the ip
address of its host
in other cases though we may want to
forward a domain to another domain on
the internet
instead of an ip address in which case a
canonical name or cname record would be
used
we have mx records for email and we can
store arbitrary data with text records
which is
often used to communicate with third
parties to verify ownership of the
domain and finally we have the ns or
name server record a url that the
internet can ping to find our ip address
and there's almost always two of them
for better reliability
this has been the domain name system in
100 seconds hit the like button if you
want to see more short videos like this
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one